so hello everybody it is coming very
close to Christmas in a few days I was
really hoping to put out my video
analysis about gremlins a little bit
earlier it seems like it might be coming
out on the 24th of December which is
actually quite horrible I'll try to get
it out on the 23rd but it seems like it
might be coming out on the 24th so um
just to kind of compensate because I
feel bad about that I thought I'd add
one more video this month and I thought
I would do it on an interpretation of a
mother Goose rhyme little jack horner I
haven't explored mother Goose rhymes
until now I thought it'd be an
opportunity not only to look into the
wealth that Nursery Rhymes offer us but
also another a little more one more step
in understanding on how symbolism lays
itself out
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so as I've said before in other videos
what's important to understand when we
look at this Nursery Rhyme is to look at
the structure if you go online if you go
on the Wikipedia page and you try to
understand the meaning of this Nursery
Rhyme you will find all kinds of
theories about some historical grounding
in the Middle Ages or in you know later
history and how it appeared in the 18th
century as social commentary on this or
that event and you would you'll find is
that it's not clear exactly where it
comes from and to be to be honest my
point is that it's not that important
what's important is that out of the
thousands of nursery rhymes or songs
that came about in those times this song
was kept and his song was selected and
the reason why it was kept and selected
is because it taps into something which
is deeper the structure of the nursery
rhyme
taps into a deeper reality and in fact
it can help us to understand some of the
symbolism which surrounds Christmas and
I've done a few videos on Christmas
recently focusing on let's call it you
know the positive aspects of
Christianity but this particular the
positive aspects of Christmas this
particular nursery rhyme actually shows
us a flipside of the symbolism of
Christmas the negative aspect of the
whole symbolic structure around which
Christmas organizes itself related of
course to the Solstice now first of all
let's look at the element so you have
this little jack horner
who goes and sits in a corner and he's
eating his christmas pie so he puts in
his thumb pulls out of plum and he says
what a good boy am i so this this
nursery rhyme is amazing it it functions
on so many levels it's going to be very
difficult for me to fully unravel all
the oh the beautiful symbolism that is
in this nursery rhyme so let's kind of
start and we'll go at it line by line
hopefully we can get to two uh I can get
to show you the mystery now first of all
Jack Horner there are two things in that
name little Jack Horner so the first is
the jack part the jack part is it's
complicated jack is a figure which
appears in many Nursery Rhymes many
stories and the jack has to do with
Jacob it relates to the notion of Jacob
it has to do with this idea of it has to
do with this idea of how the just can
somehow be a trickster and how the this
I talked about you know this notion of
the trickster as flipping things upside
down but that at the end of something
the trickster can also flip things back
on their feet and so jack has to has to
do with this idea you see it in the
story of Jack and the Beanstalk where he
you know he's he's a thief but his
thievery you know is able to restart his
family's story by stealing from the
abettin from the Giants he goes into
this world of dark Giants and he's able
to steal from them and by doing that he
restarts the cycle of his family which
was poor in which it didn't have
anything now this nursery rhyme has the
same structure and so we'll go through
it we'll get to it now little jack
horner so the jack for
the jack has to do with this notion of
the trickster which goes who goes to the
edge and is able to flip things around
then Horner the the notion of Horner you
have to see it as rhyming with corner of
course I've told you about in other
videos about the relationship between
certain words symbolism I haven't gone a
lot into word symbolism because it's
it's difficult to talk about just in a
video and it also can seem very very
obscure to people but there are
relationships of words etymological
relationship but also sonner you know
sound relationships which you meaning
can appear in the relationships of
sounds between different words so Horner
and corner horn has Horner has to do
with horn and so this idea of a horn now
horn corn crown all these words are
related to each other in terms of their
meaning the notion of a a crown on on on
the head of a king is related to the
word Horn the I've talked about this in
the notion that in Hebrew for example
there's a word which in which the word
for glory and the word for crown the
word for horn they're all the same in
all it leads it led to a confusion or a
let's say a very mysterious
interpretation in the Western Church
where when Moses comes down from the
mountain and it says you know and he it
says that he had glory that he was
shining and people couldn't look at him
you could also interpret it as he had
horns on his head and so he and and and
so you could see medieval representation
of Moses with these horns on his head
and so you can see it that you have a
horn the idea of a corner the idea of a
crown with all these points all of this
is related to the same symbolism that is
this idea of
moving into an extreme going into the
point of something the the place where
this comes together but also the place
where something ends okay
and so the Solstice both solstices can
be seen as these horns as these corners
where the Sun is going down down down
down down and then starts to go back up
or the Sun is going up up up up up and
then starts to go back down and so
there's a relationship between this
whole idea of the Solstice as this
darkest time this idea of the horn as
this point which which comes together
and also just this notion of the extreme
as well the idea of the extreme and this
this all the symbolism of the extreme is
extremely it's very difficult to
understand it's quite yeah it's quite
intense let's say that it's not easy to
get to so anyways let's get back to our
little friend Jack Horner so Jack Horner
sits in a corner and he eats his
Christmas pie now the traditional
understanding of the spirit of this
Nursery Rhyme is that it has to do with
a form of a portion ISM the form of
someone who profits from a situation in
kind of a bad way and so it's been
related to in Pollock for politics for
example where something bad is happening
a war or a bad situation and out of that
someone is able to put their thumb in
and pull out a plum and so forth there
are several political cartoons which
show for example Abraham Lincoln who who
you know through this whole situation of
the Civil War and the situation of the
South he has this plum which is which is
Louisiana and he pulls out this plum as
this thing that he can pull out of the
dark south as his precious thing that he
can rely on okay and so you can see it
also in terms of any type of political
situation where a bad thing is happening
and then somebody is able to profit from
it and so Jack Horner goes into his
corner and he's got his pie all for
himself he's got this pine he's hiding
in
corner you know he's not he's not
sharing it he's hiding in this corner
and then he puts in his thumb and he
pulls out a plum now there's a lot of
there are a lot of things going on in
that symbolism so this notion of
entering into the corner entering into
the extreme entering also into the
hidden place you know I've told you
about this hidden place or this dark
place in in several of my of my videos
and then in this dark place he's holding
this pie and the pot you have to
understand the pie as the bottom of the
hierarchy the pie as this food as this
potentiality but also the way the pies
made you know it's hiding its contents
and so it's like a it's like a gift
wrapped in in in paper under the tree in
you know under this under this corner
you have this this wrapped gift which is
hidden and so so Jack Horner plunges his
thumb in and he pulls out a plum now the
plum is the same as this spark the same
as the golden ball that the Frog goes to
get down in the water I've been telling
you about this symbolism forever so Jack
puts his thumb into this unknown place
you're like he's fishing you know
putting his his he's putting his a
fishing rod he's throwing his his
fishing rod out into the dark waters
then he goes in and he pulls out a
precious thing a plum a seed a you know
a pearl whatever how you want to imagine
it that's the imagery that's used okay
and then finally he says what a good boy
am I now you can see how that what a
good boy am i cuts in with the whole
idea of Christmas where you know this
notion that if you are good you will get
a gift but now you see that it follows
the very same structure this notion of
you this hidden gift he goes into the
corner into the Solstice into this dark
place to the darkest place and then he's
able to go in and find a precious thing
out of this dark place okay so it's the
same symbolism as Christmas that's the
as Christ hiding under this
I didn't under this mountain hiding in a
cave the darkest place think of that
think of a cave as a corner that goes
down and think of a mountain as a corner
that goes up and so Christ goes down
into this corner that goes down and and
there appears the hidden Christ in that
in that hidden place okay so this
structure is the same and you can see
the same for the political of fortune'
ISM that I talked about the structure is
the same but what what's important and
what what is helpful in thinking about
the little jack horner story is that it
shows us how symbolism is structural
it's not moral directly it does refer
sometimes to moral things but the
symbolism is structural and each
structure in terms of symbolism also has
a dark inversion and so in fact you can
imagine that the the this story of
little jack horner although it follows
the same structure as the Christmas
story
it is a upside down version of the
Christmas story it's a it's a dark
version of the Christmas story that is
you can see it first of all in the
notion that he pulls out the plum and
then he says what a good boy am i and so
in that gesture of saying what a good
boy am I you can see the difference
between for example the notion of being
judged by Santa Claus as to whether or
not you're good it you can see it as
Adam as Eve reaching out to take the
fruit for herself and saying what a good
boy am i what a good girl in my I am the
I am independent I am my own judge I am
my own author and so here I am going to
reach out and take this this fruit from
the tree so so Jack Horner plunges down
into the pie and he takes the fruit for
himself in a way that is it's a negative
way it's not it's not it is not it
doesn't
it shows us the negative aspect of that
symbolism okay and so you can imagine
and that's why it refers to profiteering
that's why it refers to two
although following the same structure
going into a dark place going into a
place where things are chaotic things
are falling apart there's war there's
conflict there's all these problems and
then finding the the golden thing in the
darkness and pulling it out right not in
in the notion of wanting then to restart
the world decide you've going down into
the darkness and finding meaning but
rather to do it in the in a way that is
is profiteering and is there to just
bolster my own interest in a selfish and
and fallen man or you could say and so
I've given you guys already a lot to
chew on I didn't want to make this video
too long I just wanted to to do a little
thing and because the gremlins video
might be coming out before Christmas and
if not it might be coming out on
Christmas Eve which is kind of sad to
think that I'll be talking about
gremlins for you guys on Christmas Eve
so I wanted to give you a little bit of
something too in the meantime guys check
out the I put out the December QA once
again last month I put out the QA this
month I did again because in the QA for
December I'm discussing the whole
question of patreon the the whole story
of what has been happening on patreon
and kind of my stance on it and the
steps that I'm taking to move further on
that line so check that out and as usual
you know thanks everybody for your
support it's been an amazing year and
Merry Christmas if you if you don't get
my my gremlins Merry Christmas and I
will see all of you very soon
obviously Santa Claus exists
[Music]
obviously Santa Claus exists
[Applause]
obviously Santa Claus exists